a southern highlands area creating a
whole lot of confusion for drivers a lot
of people say they've seen several cars
just running the stop sign right along
jones and people aren't really sure what
to do eight news now reporter sally
jaramillo is live near somerset hills
and south jones with more on this
traffic headache sally
denise neighbors who live in the area
say this intersection is extremely
confusing now add to that construction
and new development isn't helping the
situation and neighbors here simply want
to see change
accidents screeching honking
poor kids waiting or like poor people
trying to cross with their dog those are
just a few of the things happening on
the intersection of somerset and jones
everybody just stopping because they
don't know where to go or people are
racing rasha horn has lived in southern
highlands since september she is only
steps away from the intersection which
she describes as horrible and adds
construction doesn't make it easier
people that don't know where the stop
signs are because they keep doing
they put one here temporarily then they
move it and there's one facing the wrong
direction two weeks ago there was an
accident with three kids
so it's just scary to see this and while
the majority of the people living here
treat it as a four-way stop clark county
says it's never been that way the
intersection is a two-way i would love
if there was like just speed bumps on
that residential street so people can
slow down
and then maybe like another stop sign
here and as it gets darker they would
like to see these streets well lit we
shouldn't have to wait until something
like that happens for us to make a
change
back out live i spoke to dan kulin from
the county he tells me he tells me they
did come out here to check out the area
and in a statement he also says the stop
signs in that area are for the site
streets and other east-west roads and
there should not be any stop signs for
traffic on jones boulevard unquote i
also want to let you know a lot of
neighbors have been coming out telling
me that despite all this they would
simply like to see a four-way stop right
here sally haramiyo live local now